oui cette histoire là peut paraître fin
je vois que le président de la
république le traite avec une forme de
tête 1 et 10 en fait au fond si les gens
sont pas feints 6e mais opposant me
critique qui viennent chercher au pénal
mais la question n'est pas la question
de la levée égalité la question est
celle là même on se dit mais il ne
comprend même pas ce qui lui est
reprochée ne comprends même pas que le
fond du problème c'est d'avoir au fond
privatiser une partie de la décision de
l'état ce sont des entreprises privées
aujourd'hui selon des logiques qui sont
les logiques propres au secteur privé
qui viennent maintenant définir en lieu
et place de la fonction publique ce
qu'est l'intérêt général c'est
scandaleux on sépare les missions
ponctuelles l'administration peut pas
sur des missions ponctuelles je vais
repenser vraiment c'est l'émission qui
ont été brandis par mckinsey étaient des
missions qu'on ne pouvait pas remplir
est-ce qu'on avait besoin de payer un
cabinet privé pour nous dire qu'il
fallait mettre fin et failli baisser les
apl des français alors je comprends que
mc kinsey ait fait ce choix ça
correspond à leur logique enfin c'est
quand même pas face et on est venu
frapper des français qui sont dans des
français modestes au portefeuille tout
ça sous l'égide de cabinets américains
qui sont vus logique éviter de la part
de ces cabinets conseils et qu'ils ont
un intérêt pas il manque d'objectivité
ils ont leur propre subjectivité et on
connaît en fait leur modèle qui n'est
pas le modèle
des jeux euros pour reprendre encore la
formule conseil national de la
résistance en fait ils sont dans une
logique qu'un logiquement libéral
national de la résistance et la hauteur
ont été déposées depuis longtemps par
jean moulin et ses frères
[Musique]